معنى الدكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر رئيس مركز
الخليج للابحاث دكتور عبد العزيز مساء
الخير مرحبا بك في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
دكتور قطار المصالحات والسلام في الشرق
الاوسط لا يتوقف برايك ما الذي يدفعه بهذه
السرعه
وهل يعني الدفاع هذا القطار تصفير
الخلافات بين الدول التي كانت مختلفه او
التي كانت يعني على عدم توافق في كثير من
الملفات ام ان هذا الامر يعني تنظيم
الخلافات وتاجيلها برايك
اولا مساء الخير لكل المشاهدينك في كل
مكان وتقبل الله الطاعات من الجميع على
العموم النقطه المهمه في هذا الجانب
والنهار هنالك توجه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تبناه صاحب السمو الملكي ولي
العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء الامير محمد بن
سلمان في ترتيب العلاقه الاقليميه حينما
شعر انه لا يمكن الاعتماد على العلاقه
الدوليه الخارجيه في ترتيب قضايا المنطقه
فوجد ان الاصلح والاوفى هو ترتيب العلاقه
الاقليميه في المنطقه بدايه من العراق
وايضا بعد ذلك تركيا ثم ايران والان وصلنا
الى مرحله المفاهمه في اليمن هذه
الترتيبات المهمه هدفها الاساسي كلما خفض
التصعيد في المنطقه هنا لانه في السابق
مرحله الستينات وما بعد كان هنالك مرحله
الحرب البارده وكانت كتلتين الكتله
الغربيه بقياده الولايات المتحده والكتله
الشرقيه بقياده الاتحاد السوفيتي ف
[موسيقى]
الى ان الدوره الامريكي تراجع فعلا في
المنطقه هل ترى الدكتور بانه افضل
بالضروره لدخول لاعب جديد مهم شرقي في
المنطقه نتحدث هنا عن الصين وما حدث منها
كوسيط لاعاده العلاقات بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايران يعني العلاقه مع
الصين علاقه مهمه جدا على المستوى العربي
هنالك اكثر من 350 مليار دولار والصين
بدات تلعب دور مهم جدا السؤال هو اللي
يطرح نفسه انا بالنسبه لي ان الازمه
الاوكرانيه هي من سوف يحدد اذا هنالك عوده
لمرحله الحرب البارده او لن يكون هنالك
عوده لمرحله مرحله الحرب البارده بمعنى لو
انتصرت روسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا فهذا
سوف يشجع الصين في الاندفاع نحو تايوان
ويضعف من الدور الامريكي الغربي في هذا
الجانب وندخل مرحله حرب بارده جديده اذا
لم تنتصر روسيا في حربا في اوكرانيا فهذا
يعني ان الهيمنه الامريكيه الغربيه سوف
تظل قائمه
سوف يضعف ايضا من دور الدور الصيني الصيني
بلد لها علاقه اقتصاديه قويه مع الدول
العربيه ومع المملكه بالذات المملكه
الشركه الاكبر والاهم بالنسبه لها والدور
السياسي الصيني الجديد مرحب به بكل معنى
الكلمه لان المملكه قبلت بالوساطه الصينيه
فيما يتعلق بالازمه الايرانيه كطرف ضامن
للسلوك الايراني وما ينتج عنه من تصرفات
دكتور يعني اليوم هل باتا من الضروري
اتجاه الدول الاقليميه الكبرى في المنطقه
تحدثونا عن الشرق الاوسط الاتجاه للتهدئه
للاستقرار يعني هل هي تنم عن حاله عدم
الاستقرار الدوليه التي خلفتها الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه احتمال نشوب ازمات
جديده بسبب تداعيات هذه الحرب في الشرق
الاوسط اما ان خيار المشاريع التنمويه
والاقتصاديه
والاتجاه ايضا الى تسويه الخلافات هو
مرتبط بهذه الحاله من التهدئه
يعني شو بالتاكيد المملكه تولي التنميه
والاقتصاد اهميه كبرى حتى قرارها فيما
يتعلق بقضايا النفط هو مبني على قرارك
اقتصادي له علاقه بمشاريع التنميه في
المملكه والازدهار في المنطقه بشكل عام
هذه الدول بدات تحدو نفس الحدو التركي
ارادت ان تصفر مشاكلها ايضا مع دول الجوار
بالنسبه لها ايران الان اراده تعيد
علاقتها لانها اصبحت مشغوله باوضاع
اقتصاديه ومترديه في داخلها العراق بدا
يهتم باعاده الاصلاح الداخلي ومحاربه
الفساد والاهتمام بوضع الدينار وكذا
فشعروا ان التوجه المملكه في التركيز على
التنميه الاقتصاديه هو التوجه الصحيح
ولذلك هذه الدول تحدث نفس الحدوه الذي
تبنته المملكه من هذا الطرح المملكه هي
تقود الان دفه هذا التوجه المهم جدا
بالنسبه للتنميه والاقتصاد والانسان
بالشكل الاكبر والاهم فايضا هذه الدول
حينما تبنت هذا المملكه فتح ذراعيها رح
الان باعاده ترتيب الامور للسببين اللي
قلت لك اياها هذا يفرض ايضا على دول
المنطقه ان يكون لديها الحمايه الذاتيه
وان لا تعتمد على مصادر خارجيه في توفير
الحمايه العلاقه وهي لا تريد على فكره دول
المنطقه والخليج بالذات المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لا تريد ان تكون طرفا في حرب
بارده قادمه لا تريد ان تنحاز هي تريد ان
تحتفظ بعلاقاتها المتميزه الاقتصاديه مع
الصين تريد ان تكون لها علاقه سياسيه
والامنيه العسكريه مع الولايات المتحده
ومع المعسكر الغربي ايضا تريد ان تحتفظ
بعلاقه قويه وجيده مع روسيا التي تشترك
معها في قضايا الطاقه وقضايا مهمه فايجاد
هذا التوازن يتطلب اعاده ترتيب البيت
اقليميا يتطلب تنسيق المواقف حل المشاكل
التركيز على التنميه وهنا السؤال المهم يا
دكتور يعني تسويه الخلافات بين دول
المنطقه
يعني فيها الكثير من القضايا الرئيسيه وال
العالقه التي يعني دعنا نقول لا يمكن حلها
من خلال يعني
محادثات قصيره مثلا او او مده قصيره لان
القضايا كبيره جدا يعني كيف سيتم التعامل
معها في تنظيم علاقات هذه الدول بين بعضها
البعض هل ستبقى مثلا هذه الخلافات مثلا
مؤجله او تبقى عالقه
ومحاوله الحفاظ ربما على التهدئه على
الاستقرار تنظيم اي خلافات ان ترى غير ذلك
يا دكتور خلينا ناخذ مثال المملكه حينما
انفتحت على تركيا واستقبلت الرئيس التركي
وزار سمو العهد الى تركيا الان هنالك حوار
سياسي تركي سعودي مستمر وموجود فتنظيم لكن
الاساس والرغبه الاكيده عند الطرفين في حل
الخلافات والانتقال الى مفاهمه تضمن مصالح
الطرفين المملكه لم تعد تقبل فرض املاءات
عليها ولم تعد تقبل ان تكون الطرف الاضعف
في التفاوض او في منظور المصالح هي تريد ت
في العلاقه مصالح مشتركه هذه ربما تاخذ
وقتها ولكن طالما ان الهدف الاساسي موجود
وقائم وهو الترتيب العلاقه الاقليميه
وعلاقه متوازنه المملكه اخذت موقف من
تركيا حينما كان هنالك استعداد تركي لمصر
واستخدام الاخوان المسلمين في مواجهه مصر
لكنها حينما بدات الحسن من علاقتها مع مصر
وتعيد ترتيب العلاقه معها المملكه رحمت
بهذا الجانب وبالامس كان هنالك لقاء
لمعالي نائب وزير الخارجيه السعودي معنا
ابو وزير الخارجيه التركي اجتماع سياسي
حول الاجنده السياسيه المشتركه فيما بين
الطرفين ايضا مع ايران المملكه رحبت يعني
دائما كانت تقول نريد الحوار المباشر مع
ايران ورحبت بالدور الصيني كطرف ضامن في
هذا الجانب رحبت بزياره وفد سعودي الى
صنعاء مع وفد عماني ايضا للمفاهمه حول
ترتيب الامور واطلاق سراح الرهائن والاسرى
العفو الاسرى وايضا الانتقال الى مرحله
جديده ومهمه في حوار يمني يمني هي هذا
يخدم المصلحه الاقليميه يخدم التنميه يخدم
المشاريع الكبرى يخدم الاستقرار لانه
شعرنا في المنطقه هنا ان العنصر الخارجي
الذي كان يتدخل في عمليات ترتيب الامن
الاقليمي لم لم ياتي بنتيجه ولم يؤدي هذا
الدور واصبح كل طرف من مصلحه جميع الاطراف
ان ترتب على قتل الاقليميه فيما بينها طيب
انت تقصد بهذا الطرف الولايات المتحده
دكتور الولايات المتحده بالتاكيد لانها هي
كانت يعني الولايات المتحده من 57 ميلادي
وتواجدها بعد موضوع قناه السويس والانسحاب
البريطاني الفرنسي كانت هي موجوده ولكن تو
موجوده في ذلك الوقت كان يتزامن ايضا مع
الوجود السوفيتي مكان بمعنى انه كان هنالك
مرحله الحرب البارده الان زي ما قلت لك
اصبحت هي هي لاعب طرف اساسي هنالك قضايا
كبرى ولذلك الولايات المتحده في بعض
الاحيان يعني يدعون انه اعاده تشكيل القوه
اعاده موضع القوات تخفيض نسب بالرغم انه
في الفتره الاخيره لاحظنا ان هنا نوايا
كبيره امريكيه لاعاده ملا الفراغ والتواجد
مره اخرى بشكل السؤال هل نضمن هذه
التحركات الجديده التي تقوم بها سواء
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه او الخارجيه او
السياسه الامريكيه في المنطقه هنا هل
لدينا الاطمئنان الكامل ام نحن نريد ان
نكون متاكدين من انفسنا بمعنى بناء
قدراتنا وبناء القدرات على فكره لو لاحظت
المملكه اتجهت الى التصنيع العسكري الى
الى التدريب العالي لافرادها والقوات
المسلحه لانها لا تريد الاعتماد فقط على
العنصر الخارجي وانما بناء القدرات بما في
ذلك التصنيع والتمكين من القدرات وهذا
بشكل بشكل اهميه كبيره اشكرك جزيل الشكر
الدكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر رئيس مركز
الخليج للابحاث شكرا دكتور
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات